إذا كنت تبحث عن جانب مضيء
في ظلام الوباء ، فهذه
هي تقنية mrna التي أدت إلى
لقاحات covid19 والحديثة من فايزر والتي قد تساعد
في أمراض أخرى ، فهي تتصدر
قائمة كليفلاند كلينك المكونة من 10
ابتكارات من المتوقع أن تغير الطب
بعد ذلك في  أدرج علاجًا جديدًا معتمدًا من إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير
لسرطان البروستاتا تم الترويج له
كطريقة لاكتشاف هذا المرض وعلاجه بشكل أفضل ،
ويقول الأطباء إن التكنولوجيا
ستقتل الخلية السرطانية ولكنها لن تؤثر على
الأنسجة المحيطة بها ، ويمكننا أيضًا
رؤيتها باستخدام تقنيات التصوير كأسلوب.
يُسمى
التصوير بانبعاثات البوزيترون أو تصوير الحيوانات الأليفة حيث يمكنك
بالفعل
رؤية النظائر المشعة تعمل على قتل
الخلايا السرطانية ، وتشمل الابتكارات الأخرى المدرجة في
قائمة عيادة كليفلاند علاجًا جديدًا
لاكتئاب ما بعد الولادة ،
وطب موجه
لاعتلال عضلة القلب الضخامي.
للمساعدة في علاج ارتفاع
نسبة الكوليسترول في الدم
والبدائل غير الهرمونية للهبات الساخنة لانقطاع الطمث ،
يمكن زرعها  الجهاز الإلكتروني الذي
يمكن أن يساعد في شلل المرضى ينتقل مرة أخرى
إلى تقنية جديدة لاكتشاف الإنتان
مبكرًا وأخيراً طريقة للتنبؤ
بفرط ضغط الدم وربما منعه من
أجل الصحة الدقيقة.